what if I told you that if Levi had
chosen to save Irvin back in season 3 it
would have led to a timeline where
Historia becomes a Titan shifter in the
main series we saw how the military
police wanted her to eat Zeke so that
the military would finally have a royal
blooded Titan they could control if
Irvin had survived a similar debate
would have happened only this time
around Historia herself wouldn't listen
to Aaron's advice and she'd do the
transformation even though he wouldn't
want it to happen if you want to find
out why then click the link to my
Channel Down Below to check out the full
alternate timeline where Evan got the
colossal